welcome to this video playing a look
homeys probably mispronouncing that okay
I've played him once and lost so let's
see if I can get a revenge revenge game
in an early the early Queen e2 here very
early Queenie too black can play for
this pawn sacrifice and it's very
dangerous for white you accepted just
comparable to the to the Marshall attack
it seems he wants to try moving yeah and
black just goes back to f6 for castles
rupee eight Bishop e6 that's really
quite dangerous it's not winning or
anything but very difficult to watch you
to play let's see it castles castles and
Bishop d6 next or possibly rook e8 not
sure what's better maybe start with the
bishop move okay that's uh it's rather
slow maybe ok let's let's test it start
with the route move in that case and see
what he's doing with the Queen Queen to
g5 or something maybe
Wow okay
Ruki for his playing what f4 then my
just very weakening but I can start with
this movement that looks good from a
strategic point of view anyway and I had
still EV rupee form if he goes deeper
yeah like Here I am
he has to basically play a four then and
then I can grab on d4 that shouldn't be
bad at all
getting this pawn back with a nice
position Queen g5 I don't believe really
maybe maybe if you can go back edge
Queen g5 Queen d2 maybe
and there might be cases where I can
start a really quick attack
okay plate this one and stick yeah but
it says some way to something drastic to
punish him and I probably not but I can
go to each other it's not a bad square
p'tee 24 I have bishop somewhere Wow
okay yeah okay you can take that
exchange if you like but that must be
great for black this must be good
position cannot believe it a groupie one
let's go cut this check going and Queen
D three it's very tough to believe let's
start with this check just it's best
King edge to not chief is immediately
gone and now Queen d3 I guess yeah okay
I would to see untangle them I'm just
trying to PI I'm just threatening to
pile up there should be seven rookie aid
and and things yes that's a possibility
I thought cannot do this okay I probably
have to move it there right before that
that could be an idea actually he's
still kind of cramped but that that
could be an idea okay do I have to check
yeah I probably have to
that's also the screen takes h3 idea
that's that is in the position okay I
have night f1 now to prevent Queen g3
things it's good knock when g4 maybe he
ain't hard to say not the same queen g3
and Queenie for yeah that wasn't s great
and I thought it still looks very very
nice but it's not not devastating I
rethought it would just win but that's
not the case at least the way it
unfolded and stretcher I need new units
here in this initiative
maybe you just place okay 23 with a
shampoo possibly rookie three if he
moves the bishop rupee three years yes
that that might be might lead to
something
94 94 somewhere 94 Queen age form
don't see you don't see you when I don't
believe that come on there must be
something in this position that's really
quite quite a big initiative there right
before Queen age form that holds an age
of we can take
time warning
I don't see a way like that's really
really heartbreaking here Queen the King
no crook g3 from possible Bishop g4
smashes on 1 1 G - what I didn't I
couldn't really make it work till the
end my media threatened a worksheet two
words possible 495 check that could be
yeah that is threatened protecting that
come on if I don't see a wind between
Queen to f2 or something
Queen h5 Queen f4 will win but
don't see your window I don't that's
really tough and I don't see you when I
don't believe it
check white for faith long time Howard
what am i completely blind or is there
no I'm there with all pieces yeah what
is key and I don't see a whit I come on
let's let's just go back a couple of
moves I just really want to want to want
to know what this is there ok well the
computer is on minus five so at least
I'm not completely off with my
assessment but I didn't really see how
to win this okay just once the computer
just wants to do this at night f1 all
right everyone yeah I'm not quite yet
sure what it does
maybe yeah just a check and then work
which is three that's possible
check this is the computer line know it
yeah okay well this is just this is just
huge material yeah I'm just an exchange
down of course yeah maybe I played this
and he still can defend with g1 that
death position is okay calm starts as
equal
yeah I'm not sure I mean the computer
definitely can be trusted in this
position but but the question is how
long does it take to really find out
what's going on there yeah I didn't even
see that the rook c1 was hanging but
computer actually approves of my move
one point is that if he takes there I
can take here that that I did see at
that is that is quite okay the chat even
made I only had this this idea for this
mate
that's also what okay here shakes and
again 1993 for Knight f1 is again
winning okay well I only had ten seconds
this is I can check I cannot say that
and how am I to defend my plate yeah but
this is this is kind of crazy and it
takes a stronger yeah okay that is
stronger yeah this is just very nice but
this is also looked great yeah but it
wasn't that great it wasn't it wasn't
completely clear really this one night
back i comp wants to play Bishop d7
first hand Jam maybe dance that's more
precise I was really thinking white
should fall apart somehow because well
he cannot easily develop his his pieces
there but he he defended well initially
at least here okay I didn't want to take
the pawn it did seemed like it seemed to
me that it would help him but maybe
that's not the case I maybe could have
taken that yeah I have a very
substantial compensation but now I know
this 94 g3 wins but I really thought it
would be would be much more than from
from the start okay well thanks for
watching